The electricity challenge in Nigeria
and even in broad
Africa is insanely huge.
We have more than 100
million Nigerians living
in one form of energy
poverty or the other.
We have more than 600 million Africans
who have no access to electricity.
Our goal is simple.
To provide electricity
to people that don't have access to power.
How can we build a system
that could allow people
to access power quickly, efficiently
and more importantly, affordably?
My name is Olugbenga Olubanjo
and I'm the CEO of Reeddi.
Reeddi is a climate care
company that provides clean,
reliable and affordable
electricity to communities.
The average person on
the street is able to
access electricity when they
need it, anytime and anywhere.
So the thinking was that
it has to be mobile enough
that people should be
able to move it around
but simple enough that anybody can use it.
And flexible enough that it can power
different devices at different times.
I was a curious kid,
I always wanted to be excellent,
so I'm always striving for
the best in everything.
My Mum is a teacher and my Dad has an MBA
so everybody just have to go to school.
They have like, all this educational background
and they kind of value education a lot.
When I got to Toronto,
the different experience
was that there's power everywhere.
It was like... I was just
amazed at how I could
I could get stuff done.
Basically, I just get more optimized
because you can actually
do anything at any time.
I don't need to worry
about power and I could see
my productivity quadruple.
I still have friends who still
struggle with power until now
I still have like,
I have family members
who struggle with power.
I feel I'm obliged to do
something in that regard
given my experience.
So I was thinking through
what's gonna be the best way to
solve the problem
in the most affordable way,
and the most efficient way.
I need to build a system that is
affordable, that is mobile
and also that does both AC and DC power.
I must think differently,
and I must obviously operate differently.
So for us at Reeddi, what we had to do was
to innovate on the business model side,
while also innovating
on the technology side.
So on the technology build Reeddi capsule
on the business model,
provide the Reeddi capsule
leveraging a rental model
that allows the average
person to be able to like access it.
Basically eliminating
the upfront cost barrier
that's associated
with accessing clean,
reliable and affordable electricity.
So like, the design was
done by one of my friends,
the engineering was done
by one of my friends,
and they were just, were just scrappy
just trying to get something.
And when they got it done
for me, I was in Toronto
then, the guys in Nigeria were giving,
giving us all the feedback.
They were seeing what we
are doing, testing it,
and giving us like all
this feedback about “okay,
change this model, add this
whatever, remove this and all.”
And yeah, it was, I look
back and I feel very grateful
and I’m also quite lucky to
be able to have those kind
of people because without them,
I don't think Reeddi
would be where it is today
because they basically
laid all the foundation to
make it work.
Reeddi's approach to solving the problem
of the electricity sector in Nigeria,
is to provide electricity
to people, irrespective of
socioeconomic background.
We observe that the
critical challenge is the
financing part where
people need to pay a very
expensive upfront cost to
even access the system.
Our goal is to eliminate
that upfront cost entirely
by using the rent-to-use
model that we have.
So customers just go to
the Reeddi Ambassadors
and rent the cost of
the Reeddi Ambassadors.
The Reeddi Ambassadors take
the Reeddi capsule from
the Reeddi charge station,
and this Ambassador
even increase their own quality of labor,
because they make money by renting,
by becoming a Reeddi Ambassadors
because they rent the Reeddi capsules.
And they're not bonded by contracts.
Because what we observe was that the other
the most of the existing companies
they have to bind you by contract
and all this kind of stuff.
And automatically just
eliminate the all inequality
around like all assets.
Because at the end of the day
all you just need to access
Reeddi capsule is just 50 cents
and you're good to go
and which is the same
money you use buying Coke
and Gala or whatever.
You use it to like get Reeddi capsule
and use it to get energy
to power your devices,
your phones, power your
laptops, power your TV.
I'm very socially driven with what I do
because for me it's more about the people
it's more about the impact because I got
to where I am today because
of a lot of amazing people.
And I think the more you are very focused
on people and trying to
like make sure you kind
of increase the quality of life of people.
I think it's a, it's kind
of, it's an infinite game
because at the end of
the day it's gonna be
you're gonna be solving it,
you're gonna get happiness
and they are going expose you
to like more bigger problems.
As a company, we're continuously evolving
and we are still very new to
to the game and we are actually serving
around 1,500 houses and businesses.
I think we can do
we think we can do two,
3 million, even more.
I mean, I'm kind of driven by impact.
So my goal is to bring a
smile on people's faces.
You see a problem if
you have the resources
or the capabilities to address it,
throw yourself into it, solve it,
bring a smile on people's faces,
and by default you are happy.